en el transcurso de tu vida matemática
puede ser que te encuentres con personas
que te digan que escribir que y es igual
a la raíz de menos uno está mal y si les
preguntas por qué está mal te van a
contestar más o menos lo siguiente te
van a decir bueno empecemos con menos
uno menos uno es igual a y por iu y por
y utilizando la definición de ahí porque
y al cuadrado es igual a menos uno hasta
ahí nada raro y luego dicen bueno si
fuera igual a la raíz de menos uno
entonces podríamos cambiar este y por y
por un raíz de menos uno raíz de menos
uno por raíz de menos uno y luego siguen
bueno después de esta raíz de menos uno
por raíz de menos uno utilizamos una
propiedad de los radicales que consiste
en juntar estos dos a qué me refiero me
refiero a que quieren utilizar esta
propiedad a la de raíz
de b&b es igual a raíz de a raíz de a
por raíz de b que es una propiedad de
los radicales que es bueno que se vea si
en algún momento y dicen bueno
utilizando esta propiedad
tenemos que raíz de menos 1 x raíz de
menos 1 es igual a raíz de raíz de menos
1 x menos 1 así
después de lo cual pues cambian este
menos 1 x menos 1 y les queda a raíz de
1 dejarlo escribo con color verde
brillante nos queda raíz de 1 y luego
dicen bueno pues raíz de 1 es igual a 1
y nos queda esta cadenita de igualdades
entonces su argumento es el siguiente
utilizando que y es igual a raíz de
menos 1 obtenemos que 1 que menos 1
perdón es igual a 1 y esto es
terriblemente falso y por lo tanto no se
debería poder usar esto ok
ese es su argumento sin embargo yo digo
que este argumento está mal el problema
no está en utilizar este simbolito en
hacer la sustitución y igual a raíz de
menos uno sino que el problema está en
utilizar esta propiedad de acá de una
manera descuidada a qué me refiero a que
esta propiedad en efecto es una
propiedad que se ve cuando sacamos
raíces cuadradas pero el problema con
esta propiedad es que únicamente se
puede utilizar cuando ibex son mayores o
iguales que 0 de hecho en los libros de
texto pone en esta restricción ponen
siempre y cuando bueno le voy a poner
así
y b son mayores o iguales que 0 entonces
observa no se puede utilizar esta
propiedad en esta igualdad porque menos
1 y menos 1 son negativos entonces pues
no no aplica no tenemos que ambos sean
mayores o iguales que 0 vale y bueno o
sea me he pasado estos primeros 3
minutos diciendo porque este argumento
está mal porque es decir que igual a
raíz de menos uno está mal está mal por
sí mismo sin embargo aunque sí se puede
decir que iu es igual a raíz de menos
uno lo que quiero decir también en este
vídeo es que hay que ser particularmente
cuidadosos utilizando este símbolo de
raíz déjame pérez o déjame repasar un
poquito cómo funcionaba esto de la raíz
en los números positivos va entonces no
sé
imagínate que nos piden la raíz de 4 la
raíz de 4 lo pensamos como un número que
elevarlo al cuadrado nos da 4 sí pero
usualmente aquí le ponemos que esto es
igual a 2 sin embargo hay otro número
que al elevarlo al cuadrado nos da 4 que
es el menos 2 te voy a poner menos 2
también
también es raíz cuadrada
cuadrada
de cuatro de cuatro entonces observa
implícitamente estamos diciendo
utilizando este simbolito el de raíz que
nos referimos a la raíz pero a la raíz
positiva y eso es a lo que se le conoce
como la raíz principal de un número la
raíz cuadrada principal entonces aunque
tengamos dos números que pueden ser la
raíz cuadrada este simbolito
implícitamente nos dice que nos tenemos
que fijar en la raíz positiva abajo
entonces bueno este simbolito únicamente
sirve para cuando aquí adentro tenemos
números positivos pero nos gustaría
también poder usar en este contexto para
cuando tenemos números negativos o
incluso más adelante cuando tengamos la
raíz cuadrada de números imaginarios o
de números complejos entonces lo que
tenemos que hacer es extender la
definición de este símbolo de acá y eso
es justo lo que voy a hacer lo voy a
escribir de este lado
entonces a lo que me refiero es a lo
siguiente ahora imagínate que queremos
la raíz no de un número positivo sino de
un número negativo raíz de menos x vas
entonces la definición ahora de este
símbolo va a ser que esta raíz es igual
a y multiplicado por la raíz de x
observa la diferencia este simbolito de
raíz es el clásico al que conocemos el
de la raíz cuadrada principal este de
acá pero ahora este nuevo símbolo de
raíz aunque son igualitos ya se refiere
a una raíz cuadrada compleja aquí
adentro ya podemos tener bueno ahorita
números negativos pero después podremos
tener números imaginarios o números
complejos o sea en el dominio podemos
tener números imaginarios o complejos y
de manera similar en el rango vamos a
poder tener números imaginarios o
complejos vale por el momento nos
quedamos con los negativos y esta de
aquí es la definición pero ojo para que
de adeveras aquí adentro tengamos un
número negativo y no estemos haciendo
cosas raras como esta
como ésta está de acá que nos lleva a
una contradicción lo que tenemos que
hacer es pedirle a x que sea positivo
para que de adeveras esto sea negativo
vale entonces le voy a poner aquí que se
vale solo cuando cuando x es mayor o
igual que 0 muy bien entonces este nuevo
sin boleto de raíz nos dice cómo podemos
determinar la raíz de un número negativo
vale y la definimos como y por la raíz
cuadrada de equis y si queremos también
podemos reescribir este y ahora sí como
ya no tenemos problemas como raíz de
menos 1 x raíz raíz de xy entonces aquí
sí se vale utilizar la propiedad pero
porque nada más uno de los números fue
negativo si x fuera negativo otra vez
estamos haciendo cosas raras y eso no lo
queremos hacer vale bueno entonces la
verdadera falla de este argumento no
está en utilizar este símbolo el símbolo
más bien nosotros decimos a qué se
refiere la verdadera falla está en que
estamos utilizando esta propiedad de los
radicales para cuando a esos números
negativos y eso no sabemos que se valga
de hecho no se vale
porque siempre llegamos a problemas vale
entonces por eso está mal este argumento
y ya después podemos definir este nuevo
símbolo que es la raíz cuadrada de un
negativo o de otros números utilizando
esta definición de acá y todo va a salir
muy bien incluyendo esta propiedad
claro cuidando que x sea mayor o igual
que 0 para que de veras aquí adentro nos
quede algo menor o igual que 0